we are looking at continuous probability
distributions continuous random
variables as opposed to what's the
opposite of continuous in our context
discrete very good but you've noticed
like we try and like straddle this world
okay discrete and continuous we kind of
have to sometime consider a continuous
situation using a discrete lens and we
did that in the first example looking at
the runners as I think runners and times
and we let's just break this into
discrete chunks same we can think about
it
and likewise sometimes you start with
discrete data but then you're like
actually there's like a curvy shape to
this thing actually it looks more like a
continuous thing right so there's kind
of this shifting of perspectives
now we then got to this point I'm just
going to continue from where you were
yesterday
we've got to this point is saying if you
want to work out a probability of some
range of values happening right and you
don't have to rewrite this because I
presume it's two or three lines above
what I've written in your book right we
can say if you have a function that will
match the shape of your probability
distribution then you're finding an area
under a curve and what do we use to find
areas under curves we integrate
fantastic so I'm gonna integrate from my
lower boundary a to my upper boundary B
and then off you go
right but what we did say was not just
anything can be f of X and by the way
what we gave a special name which
started PMF what do we call f of X
remember a probability density function
right very good
not just any function can be a
probability density function and we very
very quickly how to look at the two
conditions right we explained them but
in a nutshell number one you have to
have a function that is where where is
this function exist it's gonna be think
think it's gotta be the first condition
right
probably thanks Tyler some dance moves
right it's got to be positive right we
don't we don't have any such thing as
negative probabilities something can't
happen you just say probability 0 okay
so we know that's a condition and then
the other one was which some of you
would get into if you take all the
probabilities which is to say
look at all the profits London eight
that's an infinity all the probabilities
from as far left as you can go to as far
right as you can go you add them all up
and we should end up with one fantastic
okay now these are the two conditions
that we're trying to see whether this
thing meets okay does um f of X f of X
equals 4x squared and it's defined in a
particular interval from 1 to 4 does it
meet these two conditions okay now the
question does say is it right but I'm
actually interested in not just a yes/no
answer I want to know why okay
so 4x squared thankfully is not a
complicated looking function and when I
think about this guy right is it greater
than or equal to zero I feel like the
easiest way to prove to someone that is
or is and is to just draw the relevant
part of the relevant function okay so if
you have it already throw yourself up
our little set of axes right now what
I'm going to do is two things firstly
actually I've left off out of this axis
which I need firstly I'm just going to
draw by no 4x squared to look like and
then I'm going to secondly restrict the
domain
okay so I'll do this and then I'll say
okay which I am i interested in okay so
it's what kind of shape for x squared
it's a parabola can you tell me anything
else about it it's it's pretty thin it's
gonna be narrow right we remember this
from our dilation and stuff like that
what else can you talk about it
concave up because this is positive okay
hon whatever I got parabola it's thin
it's concave up where where is it
like is it is it high as a low it's
gonna be what's at the origin the origin
is important the origin is the it's the
vertex of this parabola we have words
for this I'm like I need to know what
part of it is add zero zero so I'm going
to draw something like this okay you're
like hey so I said it was supposed to be
thin I know but I don't have any scale
on this at the moment and it's just easy
for me to visualize that it's a proud a
lot like so okay so that's what the
whole 4x squared looks like but I don't
want the whole thing do why I only want
this specific domain so I'm gonna go and
I'm gonna say well let's call this one
right and then I want to have some sort
of consistent scale so
I'm gonna go one two three four so two
three four and in between these
boundaries let's see an eyeball that
there this that I'm putting in black
whoops it is it this is my f of X okay
so that stuff that I drew an orange
around that it's kind of like hey that
tells you the shape but like I mentioned
to you before often the practical way
that we achieve this is we say ah this
part looks like my Dada if the rest of
it just ignore it just treat it as if
it's zero okay so if you wanted you
could actually say it's just gonna be a
flat horizontal line over here and a
flat horizontal line over here that's
your probability density function at
least we hope so let's have a look at
the first condition does it meet that
first condition yes it absolutely does
look it's it's all about the axis in
fact even before we restricted it it was
all greater than or equal to zero so
cool I'm gonna get my green product tick
one condition but then I'm gonna try out
the second one right now we don't need
to integrate from negative infinity to
infinity because we have narrower
boundaries than that right so therefore
I'm going to take this integral from
where to where
from wonderful and I'm gonna pop it in
for X squared see what I get
okay so for x squared DX and at this
point you can almost forget that this
has anything to do with probability or
statistics you're like it's just
integration which I already know
so let's have a go what is the primitive
that you end up with when you integrate
4x squared 4x cubed on three very good
there's my premium okay so I'm going to
go from 1 to 4 that 4/3 is just a
constant so I'm going to factorize that
out in the front and then I'm going to
evaluate what's left which is X cubed
okay so I've got 4 cubed take away 1
cubed so far so good is that ok ok upper
boundary lower boundary 4 cubed is 64 1
cubed is 1 so 64 take away 1 is 63 yeah
that's okay common factor of 3 leaves me
with 21
top so that's 84 have I met my second
condition no I very emphatically have
not because I'm switched out up to 1 if
this really where I probably do the
probability density function my answer
here would be 1
so unfortunately sorry this is no good
it's not a probability density function
at least it isn't in this domain right I
wonder just is a little exercise for you
to have think about could you take this
same function and maybe maybe change
these numbers so that you did get an
answer of 1 because then it would be a
probability density function ok have a
think about that and we'll come back to
it